why do you say you can never have a good
story without an outline
I think that outlining is good and I
never necessarily have a good story but
you're going to be working on so many
more drafts and spending so much more
time than if you start with the basics
you know sometimes people don't
physically outline and they just like
think about the story whatever you do I
feel like if you track the emotional Arc
if you kind of Envision a structure and
the journey of your character
that will result in a better story a lot
of the times when I'm working with
writers one of my notes is go back to
your outline because you have a good
idea
but it's just not translating on the
page because you're trying to tell
something and you're not sure what the
Beats of the story or what the turning
points are maybe you have a good premise
you know you want to get your hero from
here to here but that is not on the page
because you're trying to jam all of this
like little ideas that you have that you
think will work but are not connecting
to the arc so I think that if you set up
an outline and again whatever structure
you follow through that structure eight
sequence approach say the cat whatever
if you kind of map where you're going it
will be much easier to get to a point
because you can see where the plot holes
are
I usually spend way more time outlining
than actually writing a script because
I've thought of everything especially if
you're writing a TV show where you're
not just writing a pilot I mean
technically you are writing a pilot but
you should be thinking of a whole show
right when you're setting up that pilot
you should be planting the seeds for 100
episodes to come so outlining becomes
even more important when you're writing
television because you need to be
thinking so ahead that sort of mapping
all of the things that you want to show
and you want to tease and you want to
set up for the future and how you're
going to actually connect them and put
them on the page in a way that makes
sense
to show what you want that show to be
can you be a disorganized writer I mean
you said you love sort of you know they
say organized versus disorganized so
whether it's like criminal or whatever
but can you be a disorganized writer and
still be successful at your craft
ah I think you can I'm never gonna say
no to something like that you know maybe
a super disorganized writer can have a
unique voice but I think that
or the nod you need a level of
organization to really tell a cohesive
story because there are expectations
there are things that need to be on the
page you need to track what you're doing
so I think that kind of having a map of
things even if you don't write it again
because maybe that's where like the
disorganized could come you know maybe
you don't actually write down an outline
but you still need to think about it you
need to you need to map where you're
going and perhaps the problem of being
disorganized is that you're going to
eventually ride a hundred drafts of your
script because you're going to keep
rewriting because you didn't plan ahead
on where you were going in a sense so I
think that outlining saves you time and
kind of helps your story much more
because you already know what you're
telling and how you're telling it and
where the plot holes are and where the
twist happens so the writing becomes
easier
let's say someone's a wealth of ideas
but they're not good at staying on task
and staying organized is that where a
Ghostwriter comes in or a script doctor
and they can kind of take the reins I
think it could be two ways I think that
yes sometimes people have great ideas
you know and they hire a ghost writer or
a script doctor or a writer to you know
write their story but I also think that
sometimes deadlines or taking a course
doing a workshop something that's
keeping you on task can help those type
of writers you know uh I like that you
know let's say a lot of the classes I
teach and things like that they're like
deadline motivated so every week you
have to turn something in I teach a
class on how to ride pitch decks and
show Bibles and every week you have to
turn in a different section and then we
Workshop it obviously and then by the
end you kind of present a more polished
version but I think that that helps a
lot of people that have problems with
that because a lot of writers you know
procrastinate in the writing they're
just like ideas or whatever so sometimes
you know either the deadline can be a
class or it can be the deadline for a
contest submission or something like
that that can help you granted there is
also the case where a lot of people just
have ideas and can actually write all of
that so then yes they would hire you
know a ghost writer or someone like that
to actually put pen to paper but even
with someone like that they would
theoretically need an outline correct I
think so I think that you still need
something to to guide you through what
you're doing
again you don't necessarily have to
write it down all the time my advice
would be to do it because it makes the
writing easier sure sure because I love
how the way you're describing it because
I've used this analogy before but it's
like a game of Jenga so if you're
pulling out a piece from here that's
going to definitely affect the stuff
that's at the top exactly if not then
that's when like the hundred rewrites
and drafts comes from because then you
forget to set things up you forget where
you're going you forget what your
central conflict is
or you're trying to tell a story and
then you told a different one so a lot
of times for example uh when I'm
teaching uh how to write you know
a coverage or have to write a script
analysis one question I always get is
like why do you need to include a
synopsis if you're working with a writer
because they already know their story
I'm like well the synopsis is to tell
them how their story is perceived
because a lot of times writers set out
to tell a certain story but what's on
the page is not what was in their head
you know and that also can translate to
outlines sometimes you set out to write
a story but you didn't plan it that way
exactly so then you ended up telling a
different story that's why for example I
was saying earlier how the log line I
sometimes don't like to know the login
and I like to write my own log line for
writers because I can tell them what I'm
perceiving as the story
you know sometimes you think you're
doing something but the way others are
reacting or experiencing or reading the
material is completely different so I
like writing a short synopsis when I'm
writing in script analysis because I'm
telling the writer this is the core of
how your story is perceived obviously
you know your story I don't need to
write like five pages of synopsis I
write less than a page but just to tell
them you know this is what I consider is
the top things and these are the turning
points and this is how I'm reading your
story
is that what you're wanting to tell
so I think that that kind of like helps
them see the story different
it sounds like it's almost similar to
actors where they think like I'm going
to become the next this person or you
know fill in the blank of the major star
and it turns out they go in for these
casting director workshops or whatever
and they say well but that's not what I
see when you walk in exactly you know
you can you're still castable but I
think you're this and then they're like
wow I never you know I didn't plan on
becoming that but that's how I'm
perceived yeah yeah so it's the same for
the writing interesting it happens also
with like you know I recently read a
script where I was like you know what
like the story you're trying to tell
they rode you know an hour-long pilot
and I was like this should actually be
like a half hour comedy like what you're
trying to tell is interesting is just
not the format it should be in so
sometimes just like analyzing it from
the side and being like you know this is
your story but the way I'm perceiving it
that should be a half hour comedy not
like an hour long dramedy that's kind of
like what I'm getting from the story
and is that is that hard for let's say a
new writer that that's like their
personal story to take it yeah a lot of
the times that's one of the trickiest
things uh to work with as a consultant
when the writer is writing their own
story because it's a delicate balance
between writing their story and writing
a story that's interesting for audiences
so I been Consulting in this story
that's very personal to the writer these
days and I keep telling them like yes
this could have all happened
but just because it happened doesn't
mean all of the steps make sense for a
story and that the emotional Arc is
there the way audiences expect it to be
a lot of the times I tell them to merge
characters get rid of some characters
bring in a subplot and
take some subplots away it's the same
way when I'm adapting a book into a
script
I sometimes merge the burst the best
friend character into one because it
makes more sense for the story to just
have one sounding board than one in the
first half of the story and one in the
second half of the stories novels work a
little different than what we expect in
scripts we don't usually bring in a best
friend character in the second half of
the story right we usually have one
throughout the story so you would merge
the two characters into one and kind of
introduce them early so they can be that
sounding board for the protagonist
so I think that that's the problem with
yes you can tell your story I'm not
saying no that's great because I believe
that if you're connected to the story
you can tell it in a even better way
than nobody else can tell it because you
have a point of view you have something
that nobody else has you know write what
you know comes from that but it's a
delicate balance between that and
actually stepping aside and being like
okay this is a dramatic story I'm trying
to get others to engage with and track
an arc I'm not just retelling the facts
that ends up being this like linear
boring thing
how does a writer figure out the ending
of their story when they're just
beginning
I think that the ending is
something that you should definitely
think about when you're starting and not
just as you're going along and that's
one of the problems I see sometimes when
the ending doesn't make sense is because
they didn't actually plot it from the
beginning so I think that the ending
always has to connect to that first act
act three is the resolution of act one
that means that what was set up in act
one needs to be paid off in act three so
those two are incredibly connected act
two is kind of where the things
go in motion and we see the evolution of
that until it reaches the boiling point
in act three but act one is where you
set everything up so if you're setting
up a protagonist that has a certain flaw
on a certain core wound for example
they're incredibly shy or they
lost a child or something happened to
them you know there's an illness or
something like that that needs to be
connected with that ending right so
whatever they you set up at the
beginning is what they need to change by
the end
so for example in even in something as
simple as a comedy like friends you know
Rachel is introducing the pilot as this
spoiled girl who lives off Daddy's
credit cards and just ran away from her
wedding you know but by the end she's
become the successful businesswoman who
gets this offer of the job of a lifetime
you know and things like that so we
track that with her but it don't make
sense because at the very beginning it
was set up that she was this type of
person but she had aspirations she
wanted more she always loved fashion
even in that first season where she was
working as a waitress she always had the
style to herself she always wanted more
and then we see that growth so that's
everything should be set up in that act
so then by the end we see it like that
whether it's a show or a movie or
whatever it's from the beginning to the
end
so when we hear people say well I let my
characters just tell me what they're
doing and they talk to me that's okay
but they shouldn't be telling you the
ending is that right we should already
know it
I think that sometimes things change as
you go along I never say never in that
you sometimes discover things as you're
writing and that's great suddenly you
have a realization that oh this could
happen to my character so that ending
kind of changes sometimes as you're
writing but at the same time
I think that if that happens then
certain things will need to change at
the beginning as well
because you didn't set up enough things
if you made a turn in the middle in a
way right everything set up needs to be
paid off so sometimes it happens you
know you're writing and you discover oh
I could add this twist you know that I
never saw coming
and I remember Consulting on a script
where one of my suggestions was okay
these two characters are Rivals all the
time but what if one of them is actually
connected to the other in a different
way you know they are the daughter of
you know their previous best friend and
they never knew about that so that makes
the characters much richer and this was
a note given after they've written
several drafts that's when I got the
script you know after several drafts
and that just like opened up the story
in a way that they never thought about
it so yes the ending changed but then
that meant that set up in act one had to
change as well so yes things can change
and the characters can speak to you you
know when I read the script I
immediately thought of like okay these
two characters should be connected in a
deeper way because then that rivalry
will be enhanced let's do that but then
obviously yes that then created you know
a backlash in a way we had to tweak a
little a few things in the beginning so
then the ending made sense
how do you teach outlining to your
students
I think that outlining is an interesting
thing to teach in that everyone
approaches it a little different the way
I like to teach it is you know with the
turning points I like the eight sequence
approach to outlining where we have act
one that has sort of two sequences
divided by the inciting incident and
then we have act two which the midpoint
is obviously at the middle
and then we have act three you know with
the climax that kind of divides that and
the way I teach outlining would be to
focus on where you're starting where
you're ending and then focusing on what
the turning points will be and then sort
of fill in the blanks in a way obviously
tracking your emotional Arc and those
turning points are always connected to
the characters so let's say we're saying
the inciting incident and let's put that
in the outline so how does that affect
your protagonist and that's why you
should be thinking about and that's what
you should be writing Not Just Like An
Earthquake happens no how does that
affect the world of your protagonist and
disrupts things so for example they were
separated from their families because
they were on vacation and everyone was
away and then an earthquake happens so
that disrupts their world because they
have to go search for their family you
know so he's affected emotionally
because of that and then by the midpoint
you know maybe they were about to reach
where the family was and realized oh the
family wasn't actually there they had
moved to a different location so then
what do I do emotionally I can't locate
my family there's no way to have a phone
or anything everything is down all
communication you know but it's all
connected to that so when I'm teaching
outlining and teaching them to track
that emotional Arc as they're going with
the beats and then kind of like filling
in the blank stuff how we're gonna get
our character to go from being this
lonely person to opening up and
reconnecting with our family by the end
and do you have them do like say one
through 24 you know if you've heard the
24 plot points is that one style of
doing it
I kind of like to let writers follow the
style that works best for them I don't
believe in imposing to students like you
should ride this way or you should write
this way I think that all methods of
writing are valid and sometimes I work
with different methods for different
stories you know sometimes the hero's
journey works better for one type Story
versus the eight sequence approach that
works better for a different one so I
think that it depends on the story
you're telling and what works best for
you as a writer because that's
eventually what's going to help you tell
the best story not if I'm imposing
something to you just letting you work
with what works best for you